this week's videos are sponsored by
manscaped and Shopify more on them after
the reaction people what is happening
there citizens of the reject Nation it's
time for Monarch episode 4 today John
how are Ru AR can't wait
man that works yeah that works for me
leave a like on this video ladies and
gentlemen also be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell get notified
when I reaction for episode 5 is up here
on the channel big thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights and as always full anthr
action watch along where you sync up
with your own copy of Monarch available
for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page over there we cover several
things exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included thank you to all
who have joined our patreon page for the
month of November hope to see you over
here in December let's get in action and
see what this episode's all
about oh o Utah Mormon
monarch
it's giving Hills Have Eyes and Breaking
Bad fine where's the atomic bomb
Jesse Jesse we have to
[Music]
radiate old hunka junk is this what the
hell it's not even plugged
in what was
it satellite phone it's Barnes I'm I'm
getting a really weird reading out here
and
Barnes Outpost
47 yeah I need to speak to assistant
director ver Duo that's a cool attention
to detail it's like her position doesn't
even matter isn't it Outpost 37 in the
thing or 38 I don't
know oh yeah right where we left
off
buddy get down get down man get down Run
come on get the
rock oh
boy you did it look over
there all that is hurt for a 2C
distraction and they literally just left
my man right there oh it's his fault man
after a certain
point the thing you could have got
killed you
idiot it is the year of retro
sunglasses that's a beautiful shot
wow in the hollow
ice
[Music]
no yeah that hurts that amount of
cold that dude looks really concerned
for her that's his love right
there I think we're in the clear for the
moment oh God damn it son of a
b whoa my legs are soaking my
got to move
quick you good am I good I'm going to
die of hypothermia are you happy we came
Jesus always
fighting yeah he was like no wonder my
dad had two families
yeah
[Music]
whoa this is an interesting
change
fair you're brand
man they don't buy into your product
they buy into
[Music]
you like his father and multiple
identities and relationships his art is
genetically passed down
yeah Mom shut up yeah stop supporting me
Mom that's why I went to Alaska show him
his art yes I brought these big faces
with me so Monarch is a commentary on
parasocial
relationships yep we all think we know
Godzilla
no so they started off bickering yeah
it's their core relationship trait
sounds pretentious
incredibly you speak English hey you
know what would be incredibly respectful
is if
you yeah delete the pick is there a
reason you don't like your picture being
taken
cuz she doesn't know who you
are it's a very nice picture it's am I
recently deleted are you hitting on me
just being honest do people say that in
real life I've seen it movies and shows
all the time are you flirting with me
are you hitting on me people are always
asking me that do you like whiskey I
like expensive whiskey you're in luck
Japan has some very expensive whiskey
how expensive we talking we can't sit
still with that Titan on the
prow you still think it's out there hell
if I know you still think it's out there
you're out in the middle of open snow or
it's around here somewhere the
temperature's going to drop by the
minute we got no food no shelter no
doole where the hell are we going we're
lost Andy's gone and it's all your
fault oh God I think I saw something
from the plane some kind of structure
looked like a big golf ball it had to be
man-made like a building or settle oh a
geodesic
dome this episode better win me over to
their Dynamics you're not in love with
them I mean they are Charming in this
flashback pretentious this place is a
dum
the that's the
password is my favorite Trope we chose
this password cuz we know it's a
dump oh my Speak Easy okay you proved me
wrong the center framing on this show
with the Beautiful hair too damn oh okay
so you're a successful artist I designed
the
lighting what no
way is that going to help them with
fighting the Hidan yeah they're going to
shine a bunch of lights on him is that
why he just shot the flare yeah he's
like I could use this I know
this I mean I didn't say it was a bad
act I mean as far as acts go this isn't
an act oh he opens his body language I
judge an artist based on their art not
on a suit and a
haircut oh the art why isn't the AR
first but influencers yeah come on you
are the the brand the brand why isn't
this stuff in the gallery these aren't
for sale I mean you could change that
and change your life people don't give
other people a shot unless there's
something in it for them that's pretty
cynical well I mean but accurate when it
money anything such as selfless is that
is there a real quality you should
probably go them the rich Pricks are
waiting you got to be there in time for
your dad not to show up miss your dance
recital not really my crowd mine
NE you get used to it hot shot
no they wanted to
kiss get back to them fighting that was
sweet yeah this is too sweet for two too
long man can't relate to these guys
[Music]
anymore we must go through the mines of
morio they called it a mine I know what
I saw I don't know what over
there what where right there what is
that very noticeable blue light maybe
you're a local settlement the point is
it's out there right let's zip line
across this Canyon you don't know how
far that is that Titan can catch you
before you get halfway there you don't
have noticed this whole time none of
them have had cold breath that is an
excellent call oh interesting I'm going
alone if I have to cuz I'm not a kid you
think you saw something yeah I know what
I saw then go and don't stop until you
find it and then get help we'll do the
same in a different direction the next
time we see canaro who'll be riding a
Godzilla yes he'll be surfing on its
back I have tamed him radiation
specifically gamma raay in the 30 exz
range where's is radiation coming from
that's a crazy thing you only see these
kinds of spikes from Pulsar super
massive black holes super massive black
hole the last time anyone saw readings
like this was right before the last
emergence event from jira and ukap flat
before G jira jira is there no one on
set to tell her how to pronounce Gojira
we got to get every pronunciation
possible so that every culture's version
feels represented that's how we Pander
most
broadly
is that
you yes it
is oh cool shot good long
lens oh no ice where this has to be a
Sound Stage because yeah there's like
things about them physically that are
distracting me of how they don't look he
doesn't look like he's actually
cold I'm just so surprised they wouldn't
let me car that back there's some cold
breath there we
go just the body like just your nose and
your ears would be like in so much pain
red and yeah like leaky nose running
call a niit pick but I want realism in
my Kaiju show
yes and the door opens up beneath him
some say freezing to death is a soothing
way to
go
[__] we're back at Dad's tent we are
going in Cycles this place it's Stranger
Than You Think it's Stranger than
anybody
knows mystery box if we don't warm her
up she's going to die take your clothes
off she needs body heat she has everyone
huddle for
warmth
oh Beau
we have entered hallucination terrain go
toward the
light he's hallucinating about this
woman he saw 10 minutes
ago it is a oh it's a fly flat tell me
why you don't want to go to your gallery
opening again why does it matter do you
Figo well it doesn't I don't think you
should be ashamed to take credit for
what you do what do you do yeah says you
I just brought you here and bured my
heart is soul you have been told me [__]
about yourself I do computer [__]
computer [__] yeah okay come on you mean
to tell me the entire natural phenomen
on from aora boreales has been condensed
to your kitchen um you need
to ignore it who's lra I'm traveling for
work yeah no look you you got to stop
calling me I'll call you when I'm back
yeah moved on so mysterious is this
still part of his hallucination yeah
things don't behave the same in a
hallucination when you get a phone call
from
lra oh it's we transitioned into her
hallucination they're sharing the same
flashback yes and they're both going
crazy out in the
snow beautiful whoa I think their minds
are connected in some way yeah it must
be the juju from the Borealis stuff if
anything happens to me get in touch with
my sister her name is lra no let's not
go there she's the only only person that
I can call let her go there I'm going to
give you her number I'm sure canara
knows how no he doesn't no [__] hope
you're not talking about
me can have to Stu that
fire this is nothing but Kling I mean
it's not going to last very long and who
knows what's in your dad's papers
theories discoveries where he went yeah
I need ideas yourself I got to say they
got away from that kaijou all things
considered pretty easily yeah you know
you just hide in a cave for a couple of
minutes and then it's gone it's just
completely gone with no
Trace hell of a
cliffhanger oh yeah let's see it oh
let's do
this stop don't
move oh damn whoa what a dick
Titan
whoa
that's pretty cool I can't run from that
thing
anymore no run run into it we can't
dismiss Bill randa's files Lee Shaw was
there he knows something that we don't
that's why he's going after the files
quiet class I'm the troll from the
basement that you try to avoid in the
break room toally fine it's not like I
work here for the afterwork karaoke
anyway oh my god get on with it man we
were here to learn everything we can so
no one else has to lose another loved
one in a Titan event bunch of people who
signed up to study giant atomic powered
monsters be a little bit more
open-minded about
it Tim that Titan didn't go after us I
went after the fire didn't go after
canaro went after that burning airplane
engine it was distracted by the
flare they wanted to eat that heat and
why did it toss that airplane like a
chew toy and come chasing after us
because my brother tried saving our
asses by shooting a flare at it and
after the flare we were the warmest
things maybe it's cuz he thinks you're
hot and this is how we beat this damn
thing we dangle the biggest brightest
hottest object we can in front of it
never been so thankful for a full
bladder aviation
fuel better than Time Square on VJ Day
what what we build a bonfire VJ Day VJ
Day what what
that going to scratch my head too long
for this what am I missing Is that real
or a joke if the time comes you ditch
him too save yourself Kate one of us has
to make it out of here alive a they're
in love now you think kiry Clemens is
the daughter of Keith David from the
thing yes he got
out hello what are you doing
here are you
real my alone
so did I that
Papa
papy
papy happy
Rand is
it now that's
cold cold
[Music]
soda what's down
there Nails teeth that's what it looks
like some type of shedding are you on
the back of a
[Music]
creature chains of shutter
speed Sinister
Tunes do like the disconcerting score
element
ments yeah I got my
[Music]
wish
whoa oh is this real this is real
[Music]
yeah what exactly is
this uh
yeah oh
interesting that's the sharpest
pencil blames his dad for
this of course
not a until now
for even the subtitles were
fading
cool oh is it that radio thing that that
girl found must be or or maybe they're
linking somehow
yeah papa was here this is always
sharpening pencils very very very
specific tick and then I realized every
time you took a
shot all you really whoa
yeah oh it's like a
scream
run light it
[Music]
up
no
oh want the power from your laptop
dinner time you son of a
[__]
whoa nice yeah well you
too let's
go run and catch the
[Music]
helicopter
cool like strange sound design for the
creatures
noises that's not
good it's like Godzilla but with
ice money
shot wow oh you want to go down there
all the answers he's been looking for I
never thought I'd thank someone for
abandoning their family but here we are
a they family just said it how you
someone had to fix the radio that I
found left the mess of shavings behind
oh she knows the shavings too He's
Alive a I hate my sister damn it damn
it oh maybe the Kaiju could eat the love
power it's the strongest force in the
universe car
sha it's an honor to finally meet
you
[Music]
yeah wow oh boy wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow
wow and now such Serene tones to guide
us out of the
episode makes me want to do a guided
meditation for sure man out on the ice
breathing
deep what's that in the distance pay it
no
mind focus on the sound of my voice you
if you actually took it serious you
would have been able to
meditate that's my problem always each
time just can't stop my internal
monologue you
know you know with that laptop you could
really um build yourself a proper
website that's true you could and you
could also use it to probably get access
to other websites to help you know keep
yourself a little bit clean yeah that's
true it's a little bit harder transition
when you got dual get some stuff the
proper tools to yeah keep yourself
trimmed for any
journey into whatever Frozen T you hear
that static over the radio thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner in eccommerce so
whether you're launching a passion
project or scaling to new heights
Shopify is the e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www.re naations
shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential
thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our
offerings Shopify has been a Cornerstone
of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce
backing businesses big and small in over
175 countries their a war-winning
support always there to guide you so
ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at
shopify.com rejects all over overc case
shopify.com reject start your Shopify
success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team Mary bsmi reject
Nation you know what the funny thing is
I already owned this product before
agreeing to do this partnership I could
have used my influencer ring to get it
for free or at a discount but hey now
you can get it at a discount cuz this
week we are of course sponsored by
manscaped as a married man who's always
on the move I value looking sharp while
keeping things efficient that's where
manscapes performance package 5.0 Ultra
comes in featuring the lawnmower 5.0 and
it is a game changer the package is
honestly a perfect gift for yourself or
for another man that you might know I'll
give this to John if anyone ask I pay
for it out of my own pocket but no
seriously this is easily the best
because it comes with not one but two
NextGen blade heads see the difference
it's good thing I have two now for
demonstration purposes so you got the
standard trimmer for a perfect neat trim
but this one the new foil blade for that
super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grouping with their Advanced
Skin safe technology plus they're
waterproof so no more crumbs on the
carpet the package just close of weed
whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I
definitely use this because look at me
I'm a hairy guy and the must have liquid
formations the crop Soo their aftershave
lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to post shave
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free gifts
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
shed 2.0 toiletry rag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing my pair
right now and the bag is perfect for all
your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code
rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's reject for 20%
off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with
manscaped thank you guys for sponsoring
this video we appreciate the both of you
all right John what did you think about
this hey I enjoyed this episode I
like I hate I don't think in one point
in the entire time we have filmed
anything together I've ever been like
what' you think of this episode you've
ever been like I did not like that yeah
I don't think what I I I
challenge anyone here to to find one
time where John's been like I don't like
this episode that's not to imply that I
didn't like this
episode not in a well yeah it's harder
in this environment because too it's
very fun getting to do this and being
able to watch it and kind it's hard to
be honest the camera point well it's
easier when it's just like you just
walked out of a movie and you don't have
to my shirt yeah my shirt John likes
everything I that'll be my specific real
rejects official t-shirt at reation
shop.com and five people will buy it and
uh we'll know all of us will know uh yes
uh uh okay so instead of saying I
enjoyed this episode I will say that
this episod I loved it I hated it is
it's you know it's continuing uh about
the same like level of quality I have
come to expect thus far for ouch for
better mostly and for you know could be
a little better in other places but I
know but the way I read it ouch
yes literal and it's all
immediate uh yeah so I hated everything
uh but I loved only the most trying to
get clicks are you yes absolutely woke
Monarch just ruining the legacy of
monsters but no uh I like that this
episode was uh doing more of a character
thing I think that it was nice to have
an episode that decisively chose one
character and went well two characters
really and went we're going to peer in
on them to kind of complement and flesh
out some of this stuff while we do the
things in the present like the things
happening in the present are like very
very very straightforward at the moment
even though you do have the cool like
ooh space and time weird you know like
oh when you get too close to Kaiju
things get strange like they're still
good at kind of stretching out this
mystery part but uh but it was nice to
have something with a little bit of
tonal contrast and contemplation to you
know balance out the rest of the stuff
that's just like we got to evade the
monster and hey we got to go find these
guys got to give John credit man when
even though he likes everything he knows
how to explain why he likes it yeah I'll
never just be like was good
goodbye there are people who will
I know and I should learn to become one
of them I know so that nobody ever knows
what I think just uh you know the basics
I'll just give everything a number and
not say anything
[Music]
else yeah
John are you done are you
done more uh I mean no I I that's my
nutshell review of the episode without
like taking everything that there is to
I like this knife that you've got here
give something to talk about John uh Hey
top uh what do you think of Kento
kentaro this episode it's clearly the
guy that you have been uh you know
champing for him you love
Karo and uh you know I've been sitting
here going like man you know I'm just
waiting for that performance to really
kick in and uh you've been here in his
Corner being like he's my favorite actor
in 2023 so what did you think did he
rise to the occasion uh I liked him more
than I did in the previous episodes I
enjoyed his flashback scenes I thought
him and kiry Clemens had I think when it
comes to chemistry with actors people
usually chalk it up to they have great
chemistry to they have no
chemistry and I don't think it's either
of those I think intermediate I think
they have middling chemistry is what
they have it is there it just could use
more flavors it's like you always feel
like I these actors wanted do the work
and they're giving him some of that I
think um it is the Baseline generic
flirting chemistry yes and then the
Baseline
bickering we're argumentative chemistry
and we both have these Hang-Ups that are
you know grave to us but maybe more easy
to resolve than we I still don't think
the writing on them is part I think
where the show lacks in qualitative
dialogue they make up for a lot in
aesthetic choices that evoke more
emotion often
times that are stronger than the
characters better Direction than writing
a th% I think everything is better than
the writing and
all I know people love the hell out of
this show and I like it I 600% on run to
me I know I I like it quite a bit and um
I think the political stuff is better
written than just character scenes often
yes depending on the characters uh and
so yeah I I mean like the canaro and the
what's her name what's kiry clemens's
character name May yes may I think it's
May yes I'm pretty sure it's correct cuz
like two minutes into wandering into the
snow he already it was like that Homer
Simpson episode when he was on his own
and he's like he's got like a beard is
in Marge's car and just's like it's been
a day
yeah yeah totally and it's like you just
watered off like 15 minutes ago I know
this show deals with like a span of time
but man I did not feel like they really
earned getting to like wandering lost in
the snow uh and and now hallucinating
thing like and I think they were trying
to imply that there's that there's an
acceleration on the hallucination
because of kaju mumbo jumbo Hollow Earth
things Crossing altitude you know like
there's there's a variety of things I'm
sure uh but I thought we got there like
really quick all of a sudden they do a
decent job of drawing mumbo jumbo that
like sells the way time passes enough in
the immediate moment but yes I thought
that it had this weird time quality in
both sets of stories which is odd
because like I kept thinking in that in
the flashback like how long is this
Gallery you've been at a bar you went
home you you made love you're in bed
you're getting out of bed like how long
is this thing and how long are people
waiting around for you and like how
close is this to the you're such a girl
I just you know for that ad that
Advertiser friendliness you know I don't
want to say too muchy bang bang they got
Biz they had their they got it on they
had
g g i don't know if I should say g day V
day yeah V Day G-spot day whoa John too
too too vulgar demonetized no a g spot
is any where Godzilla appears duh but
anyway the way time is
compressed uh is a little funky and it's
and like I and you said during the
reaction I too I definitely said it I'm
going to start saying that you said
stuff in the reaction that you
definitely did not say just see if
people pick up on it uh no I really
enjoy and am fascinated by the
Aesthetics of people on like icy
Expeditions and the hardships that those
involve and like I was just watching a
couple episodes of the show called The
Terror which is all about this doomed
Arctic Mission basically and it's like
set in a much earlier time but like
that's a show that really lets you live
in the sort of like there are overt
monster horror elements involved but
half the time you are just like in the
the real nastiness of being out here and
there were times where this was flirting
with that in ways that I liked but at
the same time at the end of the episode
when he shows up with a freaking
helicopter I I was a little bit like oh
you know I yeah I I feel like this is
like very popc corny in the way that
it's conceived because it's like really
clipping along and it like has this
sense of atmosphere that pervades
everything but it's like not paced
atmospherically in that sense or like it
feels like it needs to move in a way
that I get like I'm not I'm not upset
about it and I'm like yeah you know we
need to kind of be Globe trotting and
going a bunch of different places but at
the same time for The Unique challenges
that freezing to death presents you know
part of me is sort of like you don't
have to go full cannibalism but on the
other hand I am like I want to live in
the madness that is in that is setting
in you know yeah yeah I think there's I
think there is um I I kind of in all
honesty I feel like the show kind of
pulls his punches a little bit I I think
I think that there is an a more
interesting show out there about
Obsession and
Desperation you just saw zodiac yeah and
I think there's like a version there
that these filmmakers kind of want to
tell but they can't it feels like they
can't it feels like yeah it's like
they're being restricted from going to
all in on any one thing yeah and I think
I think they want to tell the story
about like uh people who have become so
obsessed with uncovering the truth of
the Titans and then watching what it's
done to them as people and how it's
tarnished their relationships but
everything they do is with with that is
kind of just like the it's very
boilerplate yeah like the choices of
what they choose to do with them feels
boilerplate and then once in a while you
get something that feels really rich
like with Cano's mom that felt like very
rich uh but she's the MVP we talked
about the brother and sister like a
billion time so we're going to talk
about them but yeah I think they're uh
they're kind of bland and well and the
show is all bit forgotten the sister no
they haven't I feel like no she's rising
to the occasion that's right she's best
friends with me now she's like we're not
going to let her die yeah they they went
above and beyond and and I do agree it's
it's I'm sure it's there in the in the
text and it's in the immediacy of the
moment but this was also a time where I
was like you know may really is just
kind of along for the journey here to
like add some cumber some Stakes ESS I
think kicking off with John Goodman
flashback at the start of the show is
kind of an indicator where I think they
wanted to go with this show uh like yeah
you got the Monarch people who are like
government corrupt blah blah blah but
then you got like these other people who
have given up their whole lives for it
and and that is kind of what John
Goodman's character is like like you see
what he was like as a young young
enthusiastic scientist uh explorer who
then became John
Goodman you know we should all be so
lucky just this like grumpy guy who just
hates people like but I want the truth
you know yeah that's all I have now
daily and ited enough other people and I
kind of think that's what they wanted
for everybody here is unpacking the
truth and uh you know Kurt Russell is
charming as always The Mont the Kaiju
was cool cool Kaiju I like I like the
the visual telling of the Kaiju of how
they're like slowly trying to figure out
what it attacks and how to how to
maneuver it I can't I have a hard time
getting on board with creature that is
um kind of made for the snow and then
humans can outrun it like [__] like
that really easily that really bothers
me a lot I'm like you got to know your
rules little bit here not on some weird
[__] like Purgatory land yeah you
know yeah totally this isn't a metaphor
moner this is a real monster should be
able to wreck all you people yeah yeah
like [__] like that was kind of
bothering like I feel like it totally
would have caught up with that
helicopter yeah well and it seems like
it has started like going up it would
have just R yeah I feel like it would
have enough like push off its legs to
Lunge at it or pull it in with its
suction or whatever you know
yeah yeah and like I liked a lot of that
um and I do still think they got away
from it again it was just kind of like
very Baseline and I I I am curious why
people love this show I like the show so
far with occasional scenes that I love I
kind of love the third episode um I
that's the closest I've come to saying
like oh I love that episode uh and I
think think again you know intent versus
what the actual end product is is very
different and I and for me I'm I'm
curious to know why people are so in
love with it you know like does it go
above and beyond your typical Kaiju show
or something in the monster verse that
does explore the humans yeah it does I
think it does go above and beyond
absolutely I think they put way more
attention to detail there than any of
the monsterverse movies have done uh at
the same
time does it earn like great writing
just because it's better you know well
or does or does more like like you know
what I mean like does does that does
that mean it
is it is
uh I I I don't want to sound like I'm
talking down to people who love it
because I want people to love what they
love I just I just don't quite get I'm
not there yet uh I don't see myself
fully succumbing cuz I'm like four
episodes in we and I'm really not in
love with our main characters and and I
I love like Kurt Russell and the
flashbacks when you're with young white
Russell and the scientists girl well
this episode also just in in sitting
here now it made me kind of realize like
I I just realized I said I don't like
the people of color Yes uh but I love my
white man c yeah and his white son W but
I F I can't stand well the writers of
the cast need to
how that
sounded oh well this this episode
especially sitting discussing it now
like it I really did I think kind of
share your your enjoyment overall of the
third episode and that enthusiasm and
the third episode in some ways is the
most meaningfully uh I thought this
meandered are we on five four this is
four yeah so like the last one was the
most sort of we spent meaningful like
development time in the the 50s plot
line and this had none of the 50s plot
line and I feel like that is my favorite
plot line easily so much more intriguing
and the characters in that one while
they're not like cuz that's when it's
like monarch Origins yeah which is
really cool and you get the fun Sheen of
the period piece stuff the aesthetic and
and uh and and like the thing is the
three of them the trio of characters at
the center of that are the closest the
show gets to like actually having some
interesting characters where I'm not
sitting here going oh this is like and
they are archetypical they are familiar
but but more less so than the present
day where i'm like this is like you know
you open up the box of like oh I got to
get my wife back or like oh you know we
got all these kind of tropy character
things and yeah like when those plot
threads seem to all kind of be what the
main uh present day story is kind of
riding off of and it's like yeah you
have them doing their romantic bickering
and stuff like that and then we see how
they met and yeah everything's very kind
of familiar and it's weird because
Godzilla like especially the American
Godzilla movies are always kind of in
this weird pushpull of like how do we do
people and and how much do we do people
and nobody wants like a human too much
of a human drama like it's the 2014
movie but we don't want to also like
annoying and cartoonish the way like
things can kind of get in king of the
monsters sometimes like you know you
don't want humans that are unpleasant
but you don't want to feel like that's
the main focus or something and like I
feel like
they're splitting the difference by
being as like kind of generic about it
to be agreeable as possible or something
I yeah I just think the melow drama
Rings flat yeah it just doesn't feel
very alive or very seasoned the whole
thing with like I'm going to go look for
my dad I'm going to go off on my own you
made your own choice I'm like d and feel
like feel like emotionally voided at
this moment in time he's just like go
that way and if you succeed great and
we'll go this way and if we succeed
great again it's like I I recognize
intent all the way I do and it's just
when it comes down to its final
conclusion of what the final product is
it it does ring flat and then when
you're not cutting to the origins uh it
it
does ring a little like the one that's
most interesting to me is when you're in
the origins of the 50s or I find it more
interesting when they're just like
cutting to Monarch Tim man I feel like
Tim is going to rise as as an
interesting character pretty soon yeah
I'm like I really know what the mystery
is that I'm supposed to be like
intrigued by and honestly like I iess JJ
ABS that way there's some there's
something there I guess I'm supposed to
be but but I enjoy uh the pulse of
whatever is happening there I think yeah
because I'm at least like going I want
to know what's happening here when it
tickles that part of your mind it's like
ooh conspiracy like this is the the more
sort of intriguing downto Earth Secret
side versus the you know High scale
Secret side sure yeah yeah um I think I
do think uh yeah
it's okay like if you look at like
Godzilla 2014 I think Aaron Taylor
Johnson who who was kind of crapped on
for some reason as being like a boring
character yeah just Dow and and and I
don't agree with that I I really don't I
I kind of agreed with it the first time
I saw it but the second time I watched
it years later when I had like time away
to where I was able to just that hey
Godzilla's not really going to be in
this it's my second time watching it let
me just watch this movie like that that
whole character makes so much sense to
me as this kid who like loved his mom
and dad and then lost the mom and he
thought his dad went like crazy all
Sarah Conor on his ass then he's like I
don't want to be my dad I'm just going
to like toughen up I'm going to join the
military come to find out the dad was
telling the truth so it makes sense why
he become this like like growing up in
the in military background why he would
become this insane main internalized
serious person so like the body language
of his performance really registered
with me and I think everyone here has
like 20 times more dialogue than uh as
like individual characters has 20 times
more dialogue than Aaron Taylor Johnson
and it's because Taylor Johnson white is
why I
find no I'm saying that I like I I think
is such a much more compelling character
who I can get on board with than
everyone here who is given an exposition
who who has everything laid out and I I
don't I I it does B especially in
episode like this where it's like it's
not really about the monsters and it's
kind of there like I don't really I just
like I don't really care and I think
your placement sometimes of when to do
your like flashback episode is like it's
kind of a weird placement to to me to do
it yeah and especially to zoom in on
taking your foot off the pedal yeah and
I mean like I like uh Ken generally and
I like seeing a window into his
character and M all that but it also
seems like okay we're on episode 4 we're
changing the format of the flashbacks
and now we're doing this first and it
does feel a little bit like huh I wonder
why and I wonder why it wasn't maybe the
girl that we were set up to think is the
lead who is now like status 4 and all
these scenes like uh sure yeah I don't
know yeah it does sort of I'm waiting to
see if maybe the rest of the season will
draw a clearer map for that and and two
I mean I love I just feel like I'm a
such sometimes I feel like I sound like
a hypocrite because I'll sit there I'll
sit here with you and I'll go I want
more from them and they give us more and
then I'm like not doing anything for me
well the thing is the character I I get
what you mean and it's no shade to the
actors it just feels I don't know
there's something that feels like there
wasn't enough time or like people were
instructed not to go too deep cuz like I
like Kurt Russell I love Kurt Russell I
love watching Kurt Russell but here it
pretty much feels like you just plucked
fun Kurt Russell and we're like just
have your personality be the heavy
lifting for you know these scenes in
that you're charming and we love you and
I love how he's just having fun he's
just chilling and like and so it's funny
you know to me coming into this like
again big respect to Wyatt Russell I
really like Wyatt Russell but I wasn't
expecting him to do like the heavier
lifting in terms of like I was like man
you know now he's in a position where
he's like acting in a way complimentary
to his dad and like that's going to be
hard shoes to fill and now in as of
seeing what's happened thus far I'm
sitting here going why Russell is like
doing so much the heavy lifting in terms
of like bringing a character that I feel
has like a a big level of commitment but
also like feels lived in even in ways
despite whatever dialogue or whatever
like there's something about that
character and to a degree the characters
around him especially the trio there and
and when he's dealing with Chris uh
higher doll and and and all those people
like there's something that feels more
alive about those characters than the
present day characters and it's and
something that feels like they were just
allowed to go deeper when doing the
homework or or you know kind of bringing
the life underneath the dialogue out
whereas in the present I can't tell what
it is because again I feel like each
time it's it's never really the actors
that I'm upset about you know I feel
like all these people are capable but
it's something about the way that it
moves and it and it and it does like
move I feel like pretty quick even
though it's good at selling you that
it's not rushing in the moment well I
think the flashback the the the Monarch
origins in the '
50s their
characters Naturally Fit for their
immediate
plot whereas I kind of feel like they
made up
[__] to fill in because they have notes
for like well we got to give our
characters backstory we got to how do we
how do we make this more personal like
you you could I kind of get the sense
more of the notes that feel one feels
very natural yeah uh because their
development is so intrinsically tied to
the advancement of Monarch yes
whereas these guys it's like
this strange daddy issue show well it
feels like you should be heading toward
like a center point in some kind of
complimentary way where it's like yeah
you have the past where there for
Learning and and charting this territory
and setting up the structure to study it
and then something kind of dark at the
center of that that the people on the
current timeline are going to discover
that Kurt Russell maybe has to answer in
some way for that is going to be both
maybe a revelation that's I don't know
to give it some level of of heft or some
level of conflict in that like oh man
maybe this went bad and it seems like
something in the past with Monarch is
certainly going to go bad but well I
think what they are
missing and is it in the show and I'm
just not feeling it
is what was my dad looking for well
that's the thing is it feels yeah the
way it if if they had that like as an as
an element of like you know it's it's
another Trope but this is like Trope
show if if they had that Trope and they
zeroed in on that a little more like
what was my dad looking for what did he
uncover about Kaiju or the monster
Titans what did he uncover about them if
they if they had a
then it then it kind of feels like you
can have the development and not take
your foot off the pedal as opposed to
let's just slow down and show [__] of
their best story I feel like it is
technically there but I feel like what
they focus mostly on is just dad had two
families and and he might still be alive
like that's kind of it and like and I
liked his presence when he showed up
here but yeah like I I feel like while
it is technically there it's not really
something that they've done a lot to
accentuate or focus on yeah what was he
searching for what is the thing that
drove him out into this and how could
maybe Kurt Russell's experience kind of
play off that and give us some insight
into that um because I think there's a
way to do a lot of archetypical and what
when it's not working you would call
like boilerplate kinds of scenarios or
characters as long as you have and I
think it would be appropriate in a place
like this to have those archetypes as
long as you've got a lot of flavor going
on in the performances and the little
details that make the characters Beyond
just the the broad strokes and I feel
like it's taking it's taking the you
know very straightforward familiar story
mellow drama elements like really
seriously in a way that doesn't detract
from like the enjoyability of the show
in the moment but that does seem like
it's missing a sense of fun well it's
starting to I guess like I'm still
excited it's weird like these are really
fun reactions and it's a really fun show
to watch but then when you start to
break it down at least for for us it
does feel like I think like the only one
I don't know I really haven't listened
to anyone's videos on this yeah I
haven't either I haven't listened to
anyone's videos but I see like how the
how people react on Twitter and I
see uh the critic score and I'm like I
guess I'm just like in this weird camp
where it's like I think it's fine I I
don't love it though yeah well I think
that's that's partly the the treachery
of Rotten Tomatoes is that like all
those could be sevens or six and a halfs
out of 10 quite glowing from what I've
skimmed it and it does create this weird
dissonance where it's good enough that
I'm again happy to be here and would
love to see it grow Beyond this but it's
yeah it's it's a show where for the
amount of like Joy people have had over
it and just remembering recent times of
you know the different receptions of the
monsterverse movies and the up and down
Journey that that has been it it does
kind of fascinate me that people are so
glowing about this because you know it's
good good enough that I get why it's
popular anyway but yeah the fact that
everyone's like 100% I'm like this is
the moving Godzilla drama that that you
haven't felt like uh you've gotten in
various movies or whatever else like at
least of the movies even though the the
human characters can be flat um you know
it's just building to the climax of the
movie yeah I'm like at least there's
like exciting action to you know
distract your mind and and feed your
like stimuli yeah whereas this feels
like it would just be an ongoing melod
drum it really does you know it happens
to that monsters sometimes and that like
maybe they'll find their dad at some
point but like and like the visuals of
the of the of the tight ends are are
really cool
yes because it's on a television show
and a lot of the times I'm I'm like well
if I saw this exact visual in a movie
theater would I be as impressed or would
I just be like I appr appreciate it yeah
would I actually logical stance I
appreciate it would actually be w i I
think this but I think on TV you're like
wow for TV this is amazing you know I
feel like this for me like this could
have been the ice episode you know or
like the Arctic whatever wherever they
Alaska this could have been the thing
yeah this could have been the thing
episode or the the something episode
whereas like you know this is a pretty
good episode four to me but I feel like
the the the ever like all the trappings
of this could have been like I you think
coming to The psychosis of the
past that that was just like it it
didn't seem like it had anything really
to do with the immediate plot it was
just like they're in the ice and they
hallucina well it seems like the only
reason of mentioning the the fact that
all like time and space are sort of
weird and funky and different around
Kaiju is just to explain way that one
Loop they do and to kind of bolster the
transitions when he's like wandering
around and then the radio brings him out
of the flashback and all of a sudden
he's inside like but generally it
doesn't feel like that sense of magic is
like or that you know strange sci-fi is
like truly everywhere here I can't just
turn off my brain and have fun with it I
I can't cuz I'm so distracted by a
potential and B weakness you know I am
distracted cuz the show treats it like
it's [__] Prestige television is
working hard enough on certain things to
clearly indicate that it wants to do
that but it's also not really paying
much M to certain other things that are
essential to actually becoming that it's
so strange to watch so I mean honestly
this might have been my like least
favorite episode of them all in some way
like for for impact again like the
promise of the setting and the kinds of
movies you could omage just the kinds of
situations you could homage in this
place are like nice and Rich and so in
the moment I think you're you're always
kind of benefiting of the doubt because
you're like oh maybe some kind of real
set piece is going to give away but the
fact that they outran that Kaiju like
twice with her legs freezing off that
really bothers me it really does I'm
like this is kind of [__] honestly
you know a little bit like they're not
just combating like running in the snow
they've also got a mild snowfall they're
fighting against that FL apparently
fluctuates between storm to
snowfall and and and I I just like
there's no way there's no way they would
have outran this [__] this is you're on
this Monster's Turf I'll give you the
beginning I'll give you the beginning
but the very end moment like what no
yeah no and it undercuts the threat it
does it's it's it really annoys me and
that whole thing happens pretty fast
like when he showed up with the
helicopter I was actually kind of
disconcerted at first I was like wait a
wait a minute who's flying right now you
sure yeah how'd you get here so quick
you know but yeah uh uh yeah it it's
it's really fun in the moment and you
keep hoping that something else is
around the corner and I think that's
what the mystery box element does and
that's why I'm worried about the JJ
Abrams of this because I think in some
ways that's a great tone like I think
it's stuff like lost I'm like that's the
kind of tone you want for a monarch show
sort of creeping conspiratorial dread uh
but also I'm just aware that sometimes
those mystery boxes don't have anything
in them you know except for Vibes which
are cool but uh
yeah I like kentaro's house his art show
is
fun interesting I guess an interesting I
don't know I it's it's it's not a bad
choice but at the same time it is one of
those I have so many other questions I
shouldn't be having because of stuff
like that yeah I don't uh I I don't this
is my least favorite of them all I still
like the
show it's done enough good things for me
to to like it um but I guess I just I'm
not over the moon about it uh and that's
all that's missing for me is uh being
more
enthusiastic sort of missing yeah so
intermittent um but what do you guys
think are you in love with it are you
mad at us oh don't bead you make it this
far I'm not reading the comments on this
oh you should all I like is that woke
trash Doctor Who that's right H the MEEP
the meeps coming for you g your woke ass
pronouns yeah screw anybody who uses a
pronoun as if doctor who hasn't had very
over cheesy writing countless times
never they ruined Doctor Who I'm like
there's way worse drct who epod I have a
feeling that this is in a well-
ingrained tradition across shows like
doctor
Star Trek various other things terrible
terrible Doctor Who epodes that was that
was one where I was like uh the audience
the the reception of a certain crowd is
going to be insanely predictable and I'm
also going to be here
going you guys clearly don't know Doctor
Who because you guys clearly tuned in
just now there are some shittier
episodes for sure yeah some with thinner
Veil attempts at uh you know you know
there's channels out there who are like
they about trans people and they
acknowledged the existence of and they
were on the nose about it h i need to
pretend to be
mad this is really taking away from my
ability to thrive as a human being right
now need to pretend to be mad so that
way could get my views this is about me
and it is
distressing yeah I need this
fixed H it's okay it's okay you knew it
was
coming as long as Godzilla doesn't get
woke you
know somehow they manag to slip some
Asian leads in a black lead in here too
it is cool to see um Asian people in
a in a I don't know if they're actually
Japanese um so it is cool to see Asian
people um as the leads of a show about
in the god of univ seems I mean but
clearly uh only care to make maybe one
of them the lead at a time Caucasian
creators behind the show definitely
really did a better job writing
Caucasian
characters and they don't even need to
like lean on I appreciate the effort
though like hey he actually speaks
Japanese and there's like a cultural
thing going on with the girl and I would
love if this was like really B cultural
that way they don't need to make it
about the culture but I appreciate the
intent to
to anyway look I'm I'm done Don I'm over
this SP that needs to be spilled and we
keep talking and I got my doctor who
rant out yes yeah like I'm not diving
into these comments I'm going to embrace
the fun sure because if you're upset
about Doctor Who you should probably go
examine some other things about your
life yeah like if you're really that mad
about it oh I was like I'll give you
it's overt and on the nose and I'll be
like and they've done that with many
topic other topics yeah not that's do
for you oh what a resolve that needs to
get a couple themes out is not the name
of Dr not one name one other
time it's okay ambiguous ending
sometimes but no subtlety I would not be
like that's Doctor Who for
you open to subtle interpretation there
I don't know what this episode was
trying to say allegorically the reason
the reason Doctor Who has episodes that
truly stand out like midnight like
midnight like blink oh um like the kapal
episode where he's in the time uh chest
or whatever prison yeah the prison yeah
is because those are few and far between
yes yes yes there is a steady
contrast and uh and yeah Hest episodes
Pooler some of the most impactful
there's a reason those episodes are huge
cuz they're not they're not as common
true and you got to and that's part of a
of an EOS sense SC why do you think they
stand out why do you why do you think
they stand out because the rest of the
time there's a wide range of Tes super
Exposition about it yeah let's get mad
cap and let's just throw a bunch of [__]
at you and let's wrap it up real fast
cuz we don't actually have enough time
to do
all so let's just tell everybody what
the point is and get out of here Jesus
guys Jesus [__] acting like oh God so
annoying yeah I don't know at that point
in some ways I'm like I go on the nose
because the people are going to get bent
out of shape about this if go you go
subtler on the nose you're going to get
the same reaction yeah or you'll get
people champing something for the wrong
reasons I liked it because I could tell
this is not the greatest
writing but they are so gungho about it
in the most overt way that I'm like
hey man you're embracing it and you're
doing it with a giant smile on your face
this seems almost intentional the way
that you have made this point blank
straightforward because I think you want
to to upset and RI the people who are
going to be ignorant towards you're like
weed them out yeah yeah yeah and hey
like let's I mean big respect to a broad
display of acceptance because again in
the community that that is for I I can
imagine being Overjoyed there are people
who who are completely for the message
but don't like the way it was written
and I was kind of in the middle there of
like hey there are Parts about this
writing and I'm like I do not think this
was well that moment was well written um
but there but I'm talking specifically
to the camp that's
like ruined by do
who that's the C woke that's what I'm
talking about cuz I'm like this show has
been so [__] woke I don't care what
anyone says you know that's half the
point I'm sure the second [__] black
Martha
Jones or lesbian Bill like come on Jesus
doctor one point has like a whole Cod of
like lesbians help out weren even around
for that and I'm sure that existed yeah
yeah yeah um and then people forget that
that's half of what a lot of sci-fi is
for is just for giving us metaphors to
help people better swallow just basic
tolerance anyway but uh yeah leave us
your thoughts on Monarch episode 4 and
you thought of the
[Music]
woke